[Music]
[Applause]
I mentioned the running smoke podcast
very proud of that and proud of the more
to it podcast Marcellus Wiley part of
the uh Dan Patrick Podcast Network a
weekly show it's called more to it
extended interviews across media sports
and entertainment this week's guest is
Lil Wayne here's a portion of that
before we get to Marcellus Wiley
performance was everything so it stayed
everything to me I performed in front of
caskets what what yeah with the person
with the person right there clap they
give you no no applause they ain't
getting no celebration huh they go man
listen man that was a that was an
interesting experience man I was I was
probably every bit of just 12 years old
or something 12 years like 11 12. they
you know they asked me to write like a
pawn I come right as I just wrote a rap
I wrote a verse and so I I ran the verse
about him in front in front the cat man
the whole church went crazy yeah and he
just laid there chilling like yeah
that's when I knew that you know I knew
for a fact that right at that moment
that was one of the moments where I know
I'm looking at everybody's emotion you
know everybody obviously they over
emotional they're crying and stuff and I
knew sitting back down at in the church
pew I knew for a fact it felt weird
because I was like man I feel so good
um you know I was like I feel so good I
got this reaction yeah and so that's
when I know yeah you just love to
perform man that was a whole that you
know I mean you could hear the entire
interview with Lil Wayne and Marcellus
Wiley a more to it podcast that uh Dan
Patrick Podcast Network yes Paul Lil
Wayne was hired to play a funeral
is that what he's saying he played a
funeral I well let me ask Marcellus
Wiley is is that this so they hire Lil
Wayne to perform at a funeral
yeah I think uh the word higher is loose
in this conversation but yeah he
performed at a funeral before and I
think the point of his story was no
matter what the circumstances were
obviously emotional funeral he felt the
energy he felt uplifted despite everyone
else feeling the Despair and the pain of
the funeral and he said it clicked with
him in that moment that I just like to
perform so whatever this life's going to
turn into performance has to be a part
of it who would you hire to perform at
your funeral
oh man
Outcast if I had to go there Outcast
Andre 3000 Big Boy uh wish I was alive
to hear it uh but at the same time it
would be amazing that's my favorite
group of all time I don't see if I can
make that happen Marcellus oh thank you
I look forward to it
uh we brought this uh uh first hour
uh what's the number one story line like
good or bad in the NFL let me take away
Daniel Snyder let me take care just
football the number one storyline of the
NFL so far is
Tom Brady
um I don't think it's getting the
attention it deserves I think we all as
we should give Tom Brady the benefit of
the doubt uh but just look at what's
happening right now in Tampa Bay and
imagine if it weren't Tom Brady that a
player retires a tremendous player a
goat retires comes back and then
participates in the off-season then
takes 11 day Hiatus comes back and then
says you know what guys I got a lot of
bleep on my plate which tells you his
eyes aren't focused on the prize
intently like and that's what I learned
about sports and it's something that we
all know in life but you take your eyes
one deviation off the prize oh you're
gonna go off the rails and it looks like
right now this team doesn't know its way
this team doesn't know which way is up
and in part it's because of their leader
the goat Tom Brady so for me it's just
watching that and waiting for the
criticism to start to match what he's
been doing because right now he's not
being the most focused leader Todd
Bowles the head coach says Brady does
not get preferential treatment
and he didn't laugh when he said it he
was actually uh serious when he said it
um Tom goes up to the wedding
during the week
uh I guess he misses a walk through you
know if if it was would Tom Brady be mad
at Tom if he's going to yell at
everybody would Tom Brady yell at Tom
Brady for this moment
no he wouldn't and look let's start in
the beginning Tom Bo stop lying of
course you give them preferential
treatment you better that's part of the
whole system and economy of sports you
try to be such a good player great
player that you get that human capital
and that human capital is hey if I show
up a little late or hey I get an excuse
absence where some other guy may not
because that other guy is not going to
do what I do on the field and have the
same impact so we're already starting
off from a lie my grandma always told me
you can't make sense out of nonsense and
Todd Bowles is talking nonsense because
Todd Brady obviously is getting
preferential treatment going to weddings
11 days off in training camp and that's
not preferential treatment without
penalty without punishment it's okay but
Tom Brady right now
he's having so many things thrown his
way and it seems like more than ever he
is in response to those things before he
seemed Teflon before it seemed like Tom
Brady couldn't be phased maybe it was
the culture of New England maybe it was
the protection of Bill Belichick and
making sure that outside noise stayed
outside but for whatever reason and in
part is because Tom Brady has a brand
now tb12 is a real thing he's in
promotion he's on social media that
noise is seeping in and now you're
starting to hear and see a different Tom
Brady but we're also seeing this in
Green Bay
what's going on with Aaron Rodgers
didn't get together with his receivers
in preseason
didn't know what his future was Devonte
Adams leaves and it just you know now he
wants to simplify the game plan whatever
that means I mean Matt leflore wasn't
even sure what Aaron Rodgers meant by
this
um right I I like what is going on in
Green Bay
you know Aaron Rodgers the great Aaron
Rodgers one of the if not most talented
quarterbacks has now suffered from a
condition we all have suffered from man
and it's called Uh the curse of the
gifted and if you're talented at
something we've all been tempted at this
moment when you're talented and you're
getting the rewards from that talent to
skip a step you know and they talk about
that a lot in terms of sophomore slump
or anytime you have to do something
again but you know you're good at it do
you go back to square one and if you're
Aaron Rodgers with new receivers without
Devante Adams on a new team because
every year the roster is different you
can't skip steps you got to go back to
square one especially when you're trying
to establish chemistry I just think this
is one of the curses of the gifted he
just thought I'm Aaron Rodgers these
guys are going to run routes we'll make
it happen I've always made it happen and
now you're starting to see that come
back to haunt him just that simple he's
Marcellus Wiley the former NFL defensive
and host of more to it the podcast on
The Dan Patrick Podcast Network Lil
Wayne is the guest this week and you can
hear that today Bruce Smith joins you
next week
and I know that he already taped this
with Bruce right yes okay
and if you say would you rather go to
four Super Bowls but not win a Super
Bowl or go to one Super Bowl and win the
Super Bowl
what would Bruce Smith take given the
fact that we always bring up the bills
that they lost for in a row
yeah and that's what the question was
um amazing answer from Bruce because I
thought I had really put him in the
corner with that one you go to four and
lose them all why not go to one and just
win one and that's enough but Bruce just
showed me why Bruce Smith is the
greatest defensive end of all time
all-time leader in sacks and all-time
leader in tackles his answer and I want
people obviously to listen to the
podcast to find out the depth of his
character and his response I gotta go to
all four I'm I'm going to four and
losing four
you know what I'm not uh as I sit here
not a champion and dealing with that
reality versus getting so close so many
times but coming up short every single
time I'm going with one for one versus
oh for four but you should hear what
Bruce says I think it's a different
answer than both of us and a greater
answer and I brought this up before that
we've been nominated for a sports Emmy
for this show uh five years in a row
nice now if we won one and then didn't
have the other four years of being
nominated I would have a problem with
that I would rather be nominated five
times not win than nominated just one
time and when
I mean there's a longevity argument
there's a I am great in excellence but I
have not achieved the ultimate goal
conversation we're having for me
everyone is second place no matter how
it feels if you don't win at all you
could be the you know the first loser
whatever you want to call it we're all
chasing one thing you don't acquire that
one thing being number two versus number
32 in NFL what's really the difference
so that's why I think it's almost a
zero-sum game it's all or nothing and
for me why are we in pursuit of nothing
we're in pursuit of it all let me get
that one and then move on
yeah did I sway you no no no no no I
still would go to four Super Bowls four
in a row which will never be done again
and they go to four they did lose
um
I I'd rather go oh for four than
really hard okay let's go here baseball
I just heard you guys you'd rather go in
the World Series
four or would you rather go one for one
and that one was a Dinger out the park
come on well wait a minute it's
different because if I don't have any
hits I get to the Super Bowl
it's not like it's an over I got to the
Super Bowl if I get to the World Series
and we lose
but I play well
it's not like me
more importantly uh did you ever have
that that how many times did you have a
game where you go hey can't blame me I
had a couple of sacks here yeah
I mean it's the
it's the moment in your life when you're
like walking off the field like I did
that I dominated don't look at me coach
hey ladies I'm over here but you have to
perform you have to act like oh my God I
just lost my puppy because we lost the
game and so now you're mad actually
because no one is going to go around
saying where we going tonight oh I meet
you here because we lost so we're all
dressing up the performance of losing
but in reality inside there are a few
guys like now dog tonight's the night I
need to get out so you got to deal with
that especially if you're on losing
teams and I was on a few of those losers
were there uh women like you know in
baseball they know where you are
basketball they know where you are where
your hotel is you know
how how different was it for you being
uh in the NFL well in football we know
where they are yeah
so football is funny because we have the
curfew right we don't live on the road
like baseball players and like
basketball players what curfew shoot
around chill in the room you know it's a
whole different world they're rock stars
football players we land in the city
let's say 4 P.M we have curfew at 11
o'clock but they're smart because if you
give us seven hours we will cross state
borders like guys would leave the state
and come back we got time so every
football team throws that middle meeting
around eight o'clock special teams
offensive defense a five-minute meeting
we do not need it we don't have to be
there and they throw that meeting in the
middle to make sure we don't cross those
state borders but in those two or three
hours before and after we find our way
like water and we find those ladies and
most of the time it was a restaurant it
was a strip club uh and sometimes you
just stayed in the room and you have
security take care of you man and uh you
played the next day what do you mean
security takes care of you they ask for
somebody I'm sorry I'm sorry Ty Bowles
says there's no preferential treatment
in it look when I was a rookie uh I
didn't get any preferential treatment I
was scared straight like security come
on the floor I'm like oh my God
Security's here they're gonna tell coach
I'm not gonna play tomorrow when you
become a veteran security is on your
team and so if you wanted to have
friends over male female the homies come
in town you wanted some lady to come you
want to own a different floor you guys
want to hang out Security will look out
for certain individuals and there was a
compensation package that came along
with that you took care of security they
took care of you so you would pay
security to look the other way
um they didn't have to look the other
way just don't look this way and make
sure when you do look this way you
didn't see me okay you know like I
didn't I didn't tell them how to do
their job I understand look I'm not a
part of the job description today fair
enough right very looked out for each
other fair enough he's that dude
Marcellus Wiley uh thanks for joining
the team we look forward to the episodes
that's Lil Wayne today uh next week
it'll be Bruce Smith and the uh podcast
is more to it you can find it at
danpatrick.com thank you Marcellus
appreciate it talk to you next week all
right we'll take a break here last call
for phone calls we're back after this